among us just dropped a massive new
update a new patch in fortnite is
introducing a brand new weapon and more
i'm persia and this is your gamespot
news
a major new update for among us is out
right now and it includes a brand new
store and four new roles for the game
the cosmic update as it's called
introduces a store where players can buy
a variety of items like hats skins pets
and visors while bundles that contain a
group of items at a discounted rate are
also available players don't need to
spend real money however as the currency
beans can also be used to buy the items
by progressing through gameplay the real
money in-game currency is called stars a
new xp system has been added to among us
as well so players can get xp for
killing enemies completing tasks
guessing correctly and winning matches
the four new roles are sure to shake
things up as each one provides a unique
gameplay ability the scientists can
access vitals at any time the
shapeshifter can disguise themselves as
another member of the crew the engineer
can use the vents and if you're always
the first to die like me then you can be
a guardian angel who protects remaining
crewmates this brand new update is
available now on ios and android pc and
nintendo switch among us is also
arriving in december for ps4 ps5 xbox
one and xbox series
xns the fortnight november 9th patch is
also out now and since it's a hotfix you
won't need to install any updates on
your end the marquee addition to the
game following today's hotfix is the
arrival of the combat pistol this more
powerful pistol packs a meaner punch
much like the recently unvaulted combat
assault rifle shotgun and smg we've
already seen this season the combat
pistol can be found in chests as floor
loot or from fishing and has replaced
the standard pistol which is in effect
unique to this combat variant weapon
this season as other such guns continue
to exist alongside their alternative
versions additionally the sideways rifle
has been buffed so players who equip one
from the sideways or from the drop loot
of enemies will enjoy its improved
accuracy and a longer lasting
overpowered state which already gives it
some extra kick that's all that's
mentioned in the patch notes this week
and with only one more major patch to
come this season expect things to pick
up quickly in the days ahead as we
continue to build towards some sort of
showdown with the cube queen
ubisoft is offering a set of three
assassin's creed games for free through
its ubisoft connect pc service you can
sign up anytime before november 12th at
5am pacific time to claim the trio of
assassin's creed chronicles games
assassin's creed chronicles was a
spin-off trilogy launched in 2015 with
assassin's creed chronicles china
followed by india and russia the
three-part story let the assassin's
creed lore explore some new areas but as
opposed to a large open world chronicles
games were side-scrolling 2d platformers
with stealth combat elements to claim
your games just go to the official
ubisoft site and sign in or register a
ubisoft connect account once you've done
that it will automatically be added to
your ubisoft connect library so you can
download each of them whenever you'd
like
those games were put out the same year
as assassin's creed syndicate which was
the last in the series to follow
ubisoft's annual release cadence after
unity and syndicate the studio took a
year off to rethink the franchise and
followed up with the much different
assassin's creed origins that began a
new trilogy featuring a new modern-day
protagonist with a story that spanned
through last year's assassin's creed
valhalla the studio has not formally
shown the next game in the series though
it has confirmed it is working on an
expansive platform that has been
nicknamed assassin's creed infinity that
could be a live service game that houses
future assassin's creed stories but
ubisoft promises it will still feel like
a regular series game and won't be free
to play
awesome games done quick the speed
running marathon has announced its full
schedule of speed runs for its all
online 2022 campaign awesome games done
quick 2022 online kicks off january 9th
and will feature over 130 games
throughout the week-long event agdq 2022
will also continue the online only
format that the game's done quick
foundation has shifted to during the
kovan 19 pandemic it was also used
during last year's event and summer
games done quick in august there are a
few recent releases featured on the agdq
2022 schedule including kena bridge of
spirits chicory a colorful tale lost
judgment return ratchet and clank ripped
apart axiom verge 2 resident evil
village it takes 2 and death loop death
loop's run is particularly noteworthy as
it is listed with a par time or expected
time of completion of only 25 minutes
other highlights on this year's schedule
include a halo 5 guardians solo run on
legendary difficulty a race between two
speed runners in hades and a run of the
tanker mission in metal gear solid 2
substance while the runner is
blindfolded awesome games done quick
2022 is the latest speed running
marathon by the games dunk foundation
which has raised money for multiple
charities summer games done quick 2021
in august raised 2.9 million dollars for
doctors without borders while the last
awesome games done quick in january 2021
raised 2.7 million for prevent cancer
and if you've been excited for tiny
tina's wonderland and want to pick up
the 2013 one shot that started it all
you can snag tiny tina's assault on
dragon keep for free on the epic game
store it's out right now for more
information on all of our topics today
make sure you visit gamespot.com and be
sure to subscribe to our channel so you
don't miss another gamespot news update
thank you all so much for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you